[Musique]
je t'aime très fort mais que fait très
attention sur cet engin
[Applaudissements]
tous ne t'inquiète pas on s'est trop
chaud c'est votre fouta fardeau qui ne
suis même pas présenté je m'appelle
angela sai
alors je te l'avais pas dit que vous
étiez coûté 2 destiné à être les
meilleurs
à midi c'est 7 4
ce qui sa nouvelle copine de récré ravi
de vous rencontrer d'affaires morgan
brian et tu dois être m'a dit moi aussi
alors qu'ati qu'est ce qui vous a amené
jusqu'ici parlement
on va essayer d'avoir un autre enfant
mais cette fois elle va pas prendre le
risque de le porter ils vont utiliser
une mère porteuse et vont demander
vous devez c'est toute une année à
chercher la donneuse parfaite mais quand
vous vous lancez dans la recherche d'une
mère porteuse
vous n'hésitez pas à demander à la
fugitive qui logent chez vous on sait
absolument rien qu'à la jambe aux filles
bientôt quatre ans félicitations elle
forcément prêt on le dit s'être beaucoup
mon amour
on ne sait rien le sujet tout à fait on
ne sait pas de quoi elle est capable
suis désolé rond on ne sait pas c'est
sur son passé
cora homme puisse bien voir maman et
maman est là ce n'est pas ta fille c'est
ton boulot oui d'élever un des enfants
et de porter le sourire angela est au
courant pour nous deux c'est ça la
dernière chose que je souhaite c'est
qu'elle n'est plus confiance
je suis désolé
tu crois
[Musique]
vous l'avez dit dès le premier jour ils
recommencent à ce troc
[Musique]
essayez donc tu es situation puisque la
mort de linda la vie de notre bébé en
danger
je ne veux pas perdre mon fils tu s'il
était en danger maintenant
qu'est ce qu'une chose je vais trouver
ce que c'est